this week on quadriga Ukraine can the
country come together following the fall
of President Yanukovych Ukraine faces
huge challenges Ukraine is all that
bankrupt and relies on help from outside
the country fundamental reforms are
needed to embed democracy and combat
corruption at the same time the society
is deeply divided between those who look
to Moscow and those who see their future
in Europe the country could split over
that issue alexander turchinov has been
installed as interim leader until
presidential elections are held on the
25th of May in the meantime will Russia
allow the process of change to proceed
and how much support will come from the
European Union your host this week
Melinda creme hello and welcome to quad
riga calls for secession in Crimea
Russian troops on high alert
Ukraine could still spark the sharpest
confrontation between east and west
since the Cold War so what will it take
to bring the country together that's
what we want to talk about today with
three people who've been following
events in Ukraine very closely and I'm
very pleased to welcome
Irina Sola Niko's she is a researcher at
the European University the audrina
originally from Ukraine she previously
worked there with NGOs including George
Soros Open Society Foundations and
Alexander Rahr
he's one of Germany's foremost experts
on Russia formerly head of the German
Council on Foreign Relations Bight
Center for Research on Russia Ukraine
and Central Asia
he's also on the steering committee of
the Petersburg dialogue which promotes
Understanding between German and Russian
civil society and finally it's my
pleasure to welcome Moritz Guttman he's
been reporting on the countries of the
former Soviet Union for over 10 years
during the 2009 Ukrainian elections he
traveled with presidential candidate
Viktor Yanukovych and he has just
returned from reporting on the Maidan
protests in Ukraine
Arina solo Nico the acting president of
Ukraine has said he is very worried
about the risk of separation of possible
secession is he right to be how grave is
the threat yeah there is such a threat
when a moment when we talk about Crimea
not about the whole of Ukraine but only
in Crimea we see now the situation is
very unstable and some unknown people
have just occupied original
administration public buildings but
tomorrow yesterday we should remember
there was a big demonstration of Crimean
Tatars who have like 200 250,000 Crimean
Tatars in the stimulant population of
Crimea and also quite active and they
want to stay within Ukraine so they
demonstrated for in support of the sort
of integrity of Ukraine more its
government we also talked about this as
if it's very black-and-white the
division as if all eastern Ukrainians
think one way and all Western ones
another is that right or is there mixed
sentiments throughout the country first
of all the situation on Crimea
it's really different from the rest of
the country but concerning the rest of
the country I would say there is also a
division between the generations between
the older generation which was brought
up during the Soviet Union and they are
usually a bit more not exactly
pro-russian but they have strong
cultural ties also with with Russia
concerning this division between the
west and the east today yesterday we
heard calls from intellectuals from the
east and from the West we're calling for
policy of a new government that will not
deepen the division especially
concerning the language question because
that is a very strong and important
question but we will talk about this
Alexander we just heard it it depends on
the generation ultimately is that then
an ethnic issue the fact is Crimea is
majority ethnic Russians is that what
makes it so different from the rest of
the country
it's true because Crimea never belonged
to Ukraine until the 50s when the
General Secretary of the Communist Party
who shop at that time gave it to the
Ukrainian Republic it was a brief
background on that history because that
intrigues me
why did Russia decide to give it back it
was part of the Soviet Union nobody was
thinking of giving it to crane it was an
administrative strike because for some
kind of political administrative reasons
but the Crimea did not mint from its
mentality became part of Ukraine in the
time of the Soviet Union that changed in
91 when Ukraine inherited the the the
the new leaders in Ukraine the
Democratic leaders inherited the entire
Ukrainian Republic which had been in
that form in the Soviet Union but on a
crane and in Crimea you have a very
strong ethical Russian population of I
think almost 60% and about 25% our
craniums and 12% Tatars and I think that
the rifts between the Ukrainian Russian
population the Tatars is also very big
because the Tatars with a very small
minority a couple of years ago but now
they are enlarging them so that they're
they're the minority there so the
tensions had been created already a
couple of years ago I think it's a it's
a very tense situation but I think that
everything depends on how the government
will act this completely I agree with
more in Scotland which you said because
if the government becomes a government
of consents if the government will
refrain from doing that kind of laws
which they endorsed a couple of days ago
prohibiting the Russian language as a
state language in the eastern parts of
Ukraine they could do it but not in this
situation I would say and of course they
have to give the Russian ethnic Tsar
about 20 million ethnic Russians living
in Ukraine and the feeling that they are
part of Ukraine that their cranium state
citizens so we want to talk about that
in just a minute whether
the government looks to be in a position
to handle the conflicts but first let's
take a closer look at the Crimea we do
have a short report supporters and
opponents of the political changes in
Ukraine clash in the Crimean capitals
Simferopol ethnic Russians who make up
60% of the population of the Crimea are
concerned about their future some are
talking about splitting from the rest of
the country
we want a free Crimea if necessary an
independent one we don't want to bow to
that gang from Western Ukraine who are
in power now in Sevastopol where
Russia's Black Sea Fleet has its main
base ethnic Russians have been signing
up to join vigilante groups they say
they want to defend themselves against
radical elements in the opposition
relations between Ukraine's different
groups have become increasingly
polarized one more problem for the
country's new leaders to address Venus
elliniko those pictures look troubling
indeed and we've seen one
mayor already pushed out of office in
favor of a russian-speaking and mayor
are you expecting violence in Crimea
well I hope it will not come to that but
we see the situation is very tense but
we have to remember that a lot of people
in Crimea and those Russian people they
have very Soviet they have a lot of
Soviet sentiments they remember the
Soviet times when the value of
recreation sanatoriums and they and they
could work in the sanatorium so this
recreation facilities infrastructure was
very well developed in the soviet union
and after the soit union break up broke
up
polarization process started a lot of
people privatized land near the sea
ashore so of course many people left are
left out of business if you want and
they don't have much income so they have
this kind of sentiments but I'm not sure
they really understand what it implies
having Crimea as a separate territory
whereas being a part of Ukraine are
probably moving closer to the EU where
you have a certain standards role of law
free justice maybe this is what they
weren't really but they don't understand
that TV is also a big part of the
problem I think in Crimea I am there's a
lot of Russian TV it's not very
objective that's also problem meanwhile
we have extremely contradictory or at
least to somewhat confusing statements
coming out of Russia itself Alexander we
have one Russian lawmaker saying Russia
is certainly going to protect its
compatriots in Ukraine in
if there is violence then earlier in the
week we heard very angry rhetoric than
somewhat more moderate tones coming out
of Moscow and now suddenly Russian
troops are on high alert along the
border to Ukraine make sense of it all
for us to what degree would you expect a
potential Russian intervention here I
don't expect the Russian intervention
not in the Crimean on the eastern parts
of Ukraine that's point number one
because Russia understand that that will
provoke a third world war with the West
second the it's it's I think it's also a
kind of signal to its own population if
Russia is saying that they will protect
the interests of ethnic Russians in
Ukraine because Russian society is
shocked by what has been said the same
shock had been experienced here when we
during the or before the Vilnius summit
in October where crane was supposed to
sign the agreement with the European
Union and not with Russia changed from
that from one night to another and went
over the east and not to the west then I
remember also a lot of shocks in Poland
and other countries here in the West
which were saying we have lost now crane
to Russia so now the Russians have this
kind of feelings it's free domestic
consumption within Russia domestic
consumption consumption in the
independent but also think that for that
the trash' put its its troops are alert
isn't I would say it's normal thing if
you have a civil war or you have that
kind of tensions in your neighboring
country for example if Switzerland
I hope not and never will happen but
would face such kind of problems as
Ukraine is facing now I'm sure that also
the German government would set its
troops in alert because you don't know
what will happen well it's got got man
are you quite so sanguine a lot of the
rhetoric coming out of Moscow sounds
rather like the kind of language we
heard before Russian troops marched into
Georgia some years ago what we had in
Georgia back then that was really a
military conflict so it's rather hard to
compare
with this situation I would say I would
like to add that there are also some
security questions concerning the army
base of the Russian fleet on on Crimea
we didn't talk about this so far
the Russians have their Black Sea Fleet
on on the Crimea and so the question of
the Crimea is also a question of
security of the fleet on Crimea that's
why the interest of Russia in the Crimea
is quite understandable I would say
Irina Sola Niko how do you see it would
you expect possible Russian military
action or is it just saber rattling and
domestic politics I agree that Russian
foreign policy in the knee abroad is
aimed for domestic consumption and I
have to add here that in mid 90s when
Ukraine gave up its military its nuclear
weapons there was an additional
memorandum signed by Russia a US and
other Western countries and according to
this Miranda this part is how to respect
Ukraine's territorial integrity and
Ukraine's sovereignty independence
Russia signed this memorandum and
therefore it will be a violation of an
international law if Russia introduces
its troops so I don't think it happened
in but of course there are a lot of
people in Russia also some civil society
organizations we call them so but
they're not really society organizations
which are funded by Russia and so I
think Russia has some sort of agents in
Ukraine which it can use to disability
situation this is a danger Alexander had
given that Fleet Based there in Crimea
how far would Russia let developments go
before it would want to take some kind
of action to make sure that it retains
its influence there at what point would
Russia see a red line do you think in my
view it would be a very big mistake if
the Korean government tomorrow or the
day after tomorrow decides to throw the
Russian fleet out of Sevastopol what may
that may happen then we have a next
conflict but I think there so enough not
to do it in this situation because the
fleet also provides a lot of
money to this area and gives people jobs
and so on and so on but you asked us to
compare the situation with with the
south ossetia five years ago why did the
war started okay there are many theories
still today I think the war has started
Russia went into this they found of
course the pretext went into into the
Georgian soil and start to fight
Saakashvili because Saakashvili started
to kill Russian so-called well not
so-called they are peacekeeping troops
Russian official peacekeeping troops
which we attacked by the Georgian army
Russian citizens so the war started
because of that if members of the
Russian fleet will be physically
attacked by some provocateurs what I
don't see today then the conflict will
be there then I think the Russian would
have a pretext to go and safeguard their
own fleet fight back and but this is the
worst-case scenario which we can expect
them you all seem then to be of the
opinion that we will not see a division
of Ukraine take place through
intervention from outside north Guttman
Russia had however been really pinning a
lot of hopes on having Ukraine as the
cornerstone of its economic Eurasian
Union a kind of Eastern version of the
EU will Russia do you think be hoping
that there still might be a split that
would allow it to have at least a
fragment of Ukraine as a cornerstone in
the Eurasian Union I'd say that the
fragmentation of that state is not an
option for for Russia and it's not an
option to have half of Ukraine in in the
Eurasian Eurasian Union because that
will mean a destabilization of that
whole region and that doesn't make sense
politically and also economically so the
question of this Eurasian Union still
open I will I would say that we won't
see membership of Ukraine in this
Eurasian Union
but it I also doubt that we'll see a
membership of Ukraine in the European
Union because we must not forget that
this association agreement that the
European Union is offering it's it's not
actually it's not the first step to a
membership but it's a substitution of a
membership in the European Union okay
let's say in the 15 in the next 20 or 25
years we won't see Ukraine becoming a
member of the European Union there are
of course a lot of voices here in Europe
saying Europe was way too slow last time
around it was way too cautious as it
kept insisting that Timoshenko needed to
be released from prison before further
integration what could occur does the EU
need to do a lot more a lot faster now
Arina Solanco to make sure that Ukraine
is stabilized and should it even perhaps
consider offering more than Association
possibly membership yeah now I'm pretty
sure that you have to act more easily
now and it would be good to have a
high-level group setting being set up in
the you may be Uncle America could
initiate it and offer not just financial
package a short-term financial package
which Ukrainians now so there are
different amounts estimated but Ukraine
now needs some help and apart from that
may be a signal of membership respect
you but only for Ukraine but also for
Moldova and Georgia because these
countries have moved forward so it was
the European Union there should be some
some more or less more form or approach
I mean which was set up by at the U
level but I mean it should be respected
I think because countries made progress
and prospect of maybe visa free travel
Moldova has already moved to what's
having it really in a soon very soon
Ukraine has to implement a few
conditions to vote for some laws and to
implement them it might take a few
months if there is a political will and
then there is a pretty good reason for
the also to open membership open
visa-free travel and on the association
agreement I'll have to say that over 80%
of you psyche community or 80% of a key
which candidate countries have to
incorporate international legislation to
become members of the European Union is
inside of the association agreement so
basically I think it's a step towards
membership because Ukraine will become
de facto European country in terms of
domestic standards and that will would
make an issue of membership much easier
to put on the agenda so two aspects come
to mind here in terms of what the EU can
and should do first one is we've already
seen so much tension develop along the
lines of Association if the EU were to
actually go further and offer potential
membership Alexander car what would that
mean for ethnic Russians in Ukraine and
for Russia itself would that not be a
kind of a defiance that could provoke
even more attention I think you want to
us to discuss rifts like in the cold war
between the west and Russia as heat a
little bit different also of course your
grounds and reasons to discuss it like
that
first of all three things I want to say
the European Union should now make a
very important gesture to the Maidan and
to the people who showed their adherence
to Western values open the borders and
give all of craniums right to go to the
European Union the same way as we can
visit the craniums Ukraine without visas
point number one and the European Union
in my view will be measured that says
the series the the it's serious approach
to crane will be measured where the we
are in Europe are ready to do the step
ii agree with you to 80 percent I think
that the Eastern Partnership should
develop association agreement with
countries who want who would like to
join the European Union but the Eastern
Partnership should be corrected should
be corrected you name three countries or
four who should become members of the
European Union in
the nearest future I think that we
cannot avoid also addressing Russia
Belarusian Armenia Azerbaijan this
country with the same approach they
should also have a perspective for
Europe the Russian association with the
European Union will be another one than
the Ukrainian Association of the
European Union but the process of
associating between Russia or the
Eurasian Union and the European Union in
my view is very correct and we should
try the best way is to start besides all
the signing the partnership agreements
with crane and other countries who want
it we have to start the process of
building a common economic zone from
Lisbon to Vladivostok it's not a nice
word it's I think it's it's a task for
European Union's to unite its continent
it will be more difficult with some
countries more easier with others but we
should do it so that is that is a tone
that we have often heard called for in
general it shouldn't be either/or we
need to be looking at this is how can we
bring both sides together in a
constructive way but more it's
government if we look at the facts on
the ground how feasible is any of that
Ukraine needs possibly as much as 30
billion euros now the EU is not even in
a position to fully bail out its own
members its southern European indebted
countries is the EU really gonna put 30
billion euros into Ukraine now freedom
of movement huge issue within the EU at
the moment even member countries are
rebelling against the true possibility
of opening their borders to southern you
members is that going to happen visa vie
Ukraine it sounds great what Alexander
Rahr has outlined for us but frankly
it's completely infeasible
well me me too I don't believe that this
will happen by the way we will have the
elections to European Parliament on the
same day as presidential elections in
Ukraine in May the these elections to
the European Parliament there they're a
big danger for the European Union at the
moment because we see radical parties in
many member countries
who actually have this agenda an agenda
of stopping migration to the richer
countries of the European Union so with
the European Union having these very
serious inner conflicts it's will be
very hard for the European Union to
solve the problems of the Ukraine now
what we can see in the last days what I
would like to add is also the factor of
the u.s. as I understand that the US are
much more pragmatic at the moment the
the Deputy Secretary of State came to
Ukraine yesterday with a number of
economic advisors and they will work
with the new Ukrainian government on
institutional reforms economic reforms
so what we see now is the European Union
is trying to figure out the strategy and
meanwhile the USA is already working
with the new government
I suspect that those advisors are there
among other things to find the stolen
money
we know that Yanukovych put away large
amounts of money for himself his family
and his cronies Irina Salonika I know
that you've done some research on the
role of the oligarchs tell us something
about the role of oligarchs in regard
both to the fall of the Yanukovych
regime but also now to filling that huge
financial hole they've got a whole lot
of money shouldn't they be the very
first ones to ante up here well I think
like I think like large-scale
redistribution is a dangerous notion you
know this is it will it will push all
the oligarchs really away from trying to
stabilize the situation and I think the
it's not a good idea basically
redistribution but what do I need in
Ukraine is over 75 percent tax on the
capital of the Aligarh it's a different
issue you know you can take away their
property that's not a good idea right
maybe we'll draw a red line and from now
on we start working within the role of
ball within this
the same rules of the game for all
economic subjects not just all the cars
but all small and medium business yeah
so that's an idea now but what do you
should do there are a lot of bank
accounts in the US where the kovash his
son for my former prosecutor general
other people who are close to the close
to Yanukovych who were directly involved
into violence and they have bank
accounts in the West and I think that
you should investigate this it's not
something extraordinary there is a mt my
anti-money laundering directive of the
European Union there are fat regulations
it just for the bank's to follow up on
you domestic on EU legislation basically
but of course there should be some
political push for the banks to do that
and that's what has to be done and then
of course I mean now all these
residences of Yanukovych and other
people were discovered I mean people
knew about them before but now they
became open for public as well and
people see what can luxurious building
these are how much money it cost it to
to make curtains or to paint the walls
or something else it is a state money
absolutely so maybe you can use now this
this money also to stabilize it to to
help Ukrainian Ukrainian kilometers but
meanwhile Kiev has a huge financial gap
and we've seen predictions the last few
days Alexander ah that the country could
run out of money in the next couple of
weeks
thirty billion euro price tag for a
bailout that's what they're estimating
at the moment could that go even higher
if Russia for example were to take
punitive action like raising the price
of its gas exports to Ukraine or perhaps
imposing tariffs and do you think Russia
might take such a step
absolutely if we are in the worst kind
if the worst case scenario
if we still continue with our
geopolitical battles in Ukraine
therefore my appeal again and a lot of
people here in the German government
including even whose life on the line in
the NATO headquarters a couple of hours
ago said that even NATO has to talk to
Russia right now we should avoid the
Simon same kind of front building as
existed before because in my view my
humble view the West cannot help Ukraine
alone
Russia can help China should invest in a
new crane that should be the crane
should be open to everyone I agree with
you that there should not be an expert
variation of Ukrainian oligarchs hawala
gars have basically played a very
important role during the Maidan
revolution number two they the end
convinced Yanukovych to stop violence as
well being shook did this made of did
this a couple of other oligarchs were
very much involved in trying to to solve
the situation in a in a modest way I
think that have the problem of Ukraine
as I see it it's not that we are simply
changing people now the new government
may be a government are honest people
but this system is excuse me very
corrupt and what we have to do from the
European part is to involve ourselves in
changing the system because if we will
not change the system Ukrainians have to
change the system but we can give the
right advices for them to do it if we do
not do this then let's see then the
situation will be completely different
in my view then maybe western-oriented
Oleg ours like eulogy mashenka who ruled
the country before will build her own
oligarchical system in this country
without any change and then Maidan will
wake up in couple of weeks and months
and say what did we do here I want to
come back to that point in just a moment
but very briefly if you would please
because you've made a very impassioned
plea twice now for us to bring Russian
in you wrote a book some years ago
called the cold friend why we need
Russia are you satisfied that your
government the German government has
sufficiently realized the need for
Russia to be part of the solution and
taken the right steps certainly we've
seen foreign minister Steinmeier issuing
some very clear pronouncements on that
subject yesterday he issued a joint
statement with the Russian Foreign
Minister a rather unusual step are you
satisfied your government's doing enough
to promote that kind of constructive
cooperation with race we have a change
in the Russian policy but also an
Iranian policy since we have a new judge
and here because the former government
were a little blind on seeing the
perspective of wider Europe for engaging
also Russia and solving general European
problems I think we have we need a
Europe without dividing lines I'm really
passionate about this because we
celebrate the 25th anniversary of the
break of the war of the wall Berlin wall
this year it should it should give us
some kind of sense of what Europe is
today and where Europe could be in a
couple of years again we need don't need
to have new walls some partners as I
said are very difficult Russia is a
difficult partner will never become like
Poland or Hungary for the European Union
but still we are only one continent
we're in the same house so we have to
find some kind of modus vivendi to work
or coexist with them as well for the
benefit of all so let's talk about what
the new house in Kiev could look like
the transitional government and further
down the road upcoming elections morts
Gutman how integrative is the new
government that was announced this week
are you convinced that they can bring
the country together I would say that
this new government is widely controlled
by people of Yulia Tymoshenko it has
some peopled by Alexander Brod is a
Western oligarch western-oriented
oligarch well
Timoshenko is also in favor of the
Russians she has quite a good
relationship with Putin so she's playing
the game she's actually yeah that's
that's what Timoshenko is so to come
back to the government it's I would say
it's widely controlled by it by her
party and by her people we have some
people from the nationalist party we
don't have people of Klitschko's party
in this new government so actually
yesterday it was presented to to the
Maidan square and there are no oligarchs
in this government there are no people
from the former Party of Regions
so from
from a regime so actually this is an
acceptable government I would say but
what we should understand that this
government will be in a very very
difficult role now the country the
country
you just faces huge problems and so what
we might see is that this government
will be removed after only two or three
months maybe after the presidential
elections in May and the government that
will come after this one that will be
the government and the Prime Minister
who will control the country over the
next year's
what's government a brief word on the
right-wing nationalist whom you
mentioned there you were on the Maidan
there's been a lot of controversy in
general even here in Germany about the
degree to which right-wing nationalists
played a role there on the Maidan what
was your impression how numerous were
they among the protesters I would say
that the longer that the Maidan stood
that the demonstrations took place the
bigger the role of the Nationalists
became that's I what what I would say
because the normal people the 100,000
200,000 people they left Maidan and what
stayed on the Maidan were people who
were ready to fight ready to actually
sacrifice their lives for the for this
revolution and in this group I would say
that the Nationalists played quite a big
role
so nationalism was certainly an
integrative factor in this in this
revolution even a Salonika let's link
all this now to that very dire financial
problem that faces the authorities in
Kiev to what degree do you think that
they can make the kind of very tough
economic reforms that have been
discussed for years in Ukraine and not
carried out and I'm thinking here about
the fact that the
MF would be of course a potential source
of funds to fill that financial gap but
the eye on meth froze its last loan to
Ukraine because the government was not
able to make those kind of reforms
Timoshenko in her years at the helm in
Kiev she also did not carry out those
kind of reforms is there any reason to
think that the transitional government
or perhaps those who will run for
election in May are any better able to
do that yes I think so
actually this government you rightly
pointed out that some part is excluded
from it let the party of regions and our
party but I think it was their conscious
decision not not to participate in this
government and they want to run
elections presidential elections which
cause a leader of the party he wants to
run for presidency in the main course
the charismatic former boxer who was on
Maidan that's true and then
parliamentary elections the new
government will actually be formed after
the parliamentary elections not the
presidential elections according to the
new constitution and I hope as far as I
see the people in Ukraine they don't
want to wait until 2017 that's where
elections are supposed to take place but
really to have early elections so this
government will be in place at the
moment one year maybe two years if we
have early elections and parties who
want to have polish conditions who want
to run campaigns they are not there I
think for the reasons for themselves
they decided not not to do so and and
what we see in this government some
people who are not to have no political
agenda for instance the name which was
named for the Minister of Economy
publisher Mehta he was a consultant in
Malaysia and he helped to carry out
reforms there and he his economies
professional he studied in Harvard and
as universities is the first time we see
a person like this in the government and
that's very positive and then the
Minister of Health Care he was the
coordinator of the medical service at
Maidan he has no political agenda he was
appointed or he supposed to be a point
in the minister of health care and so on
so we seen this kind of people and I
think they understand that they will
become unpopular because they have
introduced painful measures for IMF to
get an heir IMF loan in particular but I
think they are prepared for that not all
all there are professionals but
nevertheless I would like to add that
actually for a real reset of the country
of the political system we need
parliamentary elections in the near
future because actually this Parliament
it's it consists of the same people who
one month ago support mainly supported
Yanukovych and the people who left the
Party of Regions it's 60 or 70 people
over the last few days it's it's not
real politicians it's people who who are
puppets ready to go to the party that
controls that has the power and and that
is a real problem so you actually need
new people and this is also we can buy
other politicians out there if
parliamentary elections were to be held
soon arena so alone anko would Ukraine
get a better group that it's had in the
past I agree with and sander out on the
on the point that we need to change the
system and elections are it's important
for elections to be carried out
according to the new rules
what we need is open party lists and we
need proportional system this is the
best system which can bring people to
the parliament which represent societal
cleavages so that's what we need
just Prudential elections without change
the system now but in this way yes
absolutely and just a point on
nationalist moods actually so what a
party which according to the Parliament
2002 its support reduced significantly
after the protests many people who Boris
for water for some water they voted as a
protest vote they just didn't see it was
a kind of a new political force in terms
of that they'd never been in the
Parliament before and some people just
wanted to bring some fresh faces into
the Parliament but there's no many
people in Ukraine who support
nationalistic agenda and if you look at
people who died at Maidan this 20 years
years old guys if you look their
personal history they're not national is
there a businessman they were students
it's it's I think this notion of
nationalism senator separated from my
perspective in the West
reading between the lines Alexander Rahr
has sounded very much like Europe it
would more or less like to wait to take
serious action until a new government is
elected in May Catherine Ashton has been
quite cautious in many of her statements
also mentioning the IMF but of course
again they are IMF loan possibly
dependent on reforms that definitely are
not in place yet so what do we do in the
short term what needs to happen to
bridge that financial gap
you mentioned Russian support Russia has
also cut off its payments to Ukraine
what is a potential short-term solution
that could bring the country back from
the the abyss but we have to agree with
the position of the European Union and
of Russia in this case why should Russia
or the European Union give money to
Ukraine has this money again comes or
will arrive at the foreign some kind of
bank accounts of certain oligarchs who
are now more pro-western oriented we
don't want this I think that system is
to be changed and I don't think that the
Ukraine can afford to have a government
which exists only for a couple of months
they need a government of trust need the
government to whom the east and the west
Luke rein the young and the old one
should be should be look upon and we
have taken influence in Ukraine during
the Maidan revolution with the West the
Russians less but before that Russia had
more influence so we can't say from one
day to another we wait and see what
happens to this country I think there
are moral obligation to do more if the
Americans are now in with the advisers I
would suggest that the Europeans do the
same mr. Steinman or foreign minister
has suggested many times to organize the
OEC conference where Russia is also full
member like the America like Germany or
France to discuss the situation how to
help Ukraine this may be the measures to
do I'd like if you had fun one thing to
D is to the question of economic reforms
why
Timoshenko didn't enhance the
reforms neither Yanukovych and one of
the issues is for example the the gas
price for normal Ukrainians the big
financial problems of Ukraine are partly
because of this issue because they buy
the gas at one price and they sell it to
the Ukrainians at a price that is much
too low so one of the steps must be to
actually make that make the price for
the gas higher but most of the acute
Ukraine is of course will not accept
this because the creation of them is
really bad so there's a big question if
the new government will be ready to do
this if you know so the Nikko almost out
of time your prognosis on where your
country will be six months from now a
year from now well I think I see now a
lot of positive steps in the direction
of stabilization of the situation Crimea
still and the question but what concerns
the rest of Ukraine I think one good
track its government is really a
compromised government although some
parties on participate they already
announced they vote for it and I hope a
new elections will be scheduled I mean
parliamentary elections so far I see
we're on good track but of course a lot
of risks remains remain and we are
waiting for the more proactive role of
the European Union thank you very much
to all of you for being with us today
thanks to all of you out there for
tuning in see you soon